at the start we are introduced to an
elderly man named hori who lives alone
in his house his wife passed away
decades ago and his beloved dog ran away
recently ever since Corey has lost his
purpose in life as he has no one to talk
to he spends most of his time going
through pictures of his wife and
reminiscing the good times they spent
together but one morning he wakes up and
decides to do something drastic hori
buys a dating magazine and picks up a
beautiful young woman named Leslie he
wants to date her and eventually make
her his wife but since hori is old and
wrinkly seducing her is going to be a
near impossible task so he decides to do
the unimaginable that is to transform
himself into a young and handsome man
normally people undergo medical
procedures or train themselves to the
limit to appear younger however hori is
impatient and he doesn't have the funds
to visit a doctor hence he begins the
transformation using different objects
he finds in his house at first he takes
a small saw blade and trims off the old
flesh from his feet hori doesn't feel
any pain during the whole procedure but
instead he gets tickled and after this
he puts molten wax in both of his ears
and pulls them out once they solidify
this causes blood to come out of his
ears and once that's done hori paints
his teeth with correction fluid and puts
powder all over his face he also plucks
out eyeballs from a creepy looking doll
and fits it into his eye socket as for
the wrinkly face Ori has a brilliant
idea in mind he stretches his skin and
ties it behind his neck with some safety
pins how does this guy know my exact
routine for going out on Sunday nights
following this he undergoes some more
modifications with the help of scissors
spray paint blow dryers medical pills
and even hammers to give him a youthful
appearance after putting on a wig Horry
zaps himself with high voltage current
to get his long lost energy back alright
let's see whoa yeah here we go buddy
when he is finally done with his
transfer information surprisingly we see
a completely changed man he has a
dashing appearance with a killer smile
something which is surely going to
seduce girls in the next scene hori sets
out to meet the love of his life with a
small gift in hand he is certain that he
can win over Leslie's heart as expected
he does just that later we see the two
having a romantic time they eat ice
cream from the same Bowl run along the
beach go to a party and also watch the
sunset together the only problem is that
Leslie's tiny dog bacon seems to dislike
hori he keeps barking at the man
indicating that he has caught wind of
the deceit well well you're freaking old
no freak at all nonetheless horror
continues with his ways and takes things
one step further by gifting Leslie his
vintage Riley car that evening they
venture out for a ride and it appears as
if Horry and Leslie are in a fairy tale
there are birds all around and the smell
of flowers has Enchanted the environment
however things take a bad turn for hori
when the car runs into some potholes
leaving his already fragile body in a
precarious State as he tries to handle
the situation suddenly Leslie sneezes
and her face gets stuck on the
windshield in a shocking turn of events
it is revealed that she too is an
elderly woman who had undergone extreme
transformation to appear youthful hori
is left stunned by the sight and the
next second his body also comes loose
revealing his original form initially
the two just stare at each other in
shock but then they become excited and
start making out the movie ends as bacon
the dog also discloses his real face
which turns out to be old and ugly
the second movie takes place in a much
darker and gloomier setting at the start
we see three kids heading towards an
abandoned house which is known as ghost
train among them is a bully named Peter
and it turns out that he has forcefully
brought the other kids Michael and Sam
along with him when they reach the place
they are terrified to see its date a
giant Grim Reaper looms above the house
and several decapitated heads are seen
hanging from the ceiling the youngest
kid Sam wants to run to the beach but
Peter doesn't let him go after a while
they spot a skull on the wall which is
revealed to be the ticket machine the
sign next to it says one pound paroled
place without wasting any time Peter
asks the boys to bring out whatever
money they have Sam is still hesitant
about the whole idea but he has no
choice but to Forfeit his 50 pence coin
the hell else is he gonna do with it
anyway once the collection is finally
done Michael nervously approaches the
skull and starts feeding it with the
coins suddenly the ground shakes and
cockroaches begin to come out of cracks
the giant Grim Reaper also moves ready
to cause Havoc but a few seconds later
it stops and everything comes to a halt
this enrages the bully Peter so much
that he approaches the skull and starts
bashing it with a stick the other boys
shout at him to stop fearing that they
will face some deadly backlash but Peter
does not listen if eventually he breaks
the skull and as soon as he does so the
door opens the next second poor Samus
hauled inside the house in a wagon and
before the boys can do something about
it the door closes this this is the last
time he was ever seen now Peter and
Michael have to explain to dates why
they're afraid of wagons for the rest of
their lives Thirty Years Later Michael
and Peter go to the same abandoned house
to pay their respects it turns out they
come here every year to grieve the loss
of their dear friend Michael seems to
have become a wealthy businessman but
Peter is a mere cab driver whose life
has been derailed by alcoholism as
Michael lays on the flowers Peter
reveals that he still has nightmares
about that day he also blames himself
for dragging poor Sam to the abandoned
house when all he wanted was to go to
the B however Michael says that it
wasn't his fault in a shocking turn of
events it is revealed that Michael
didn't actually put the last coin inside
the skull and that is why the Grim
Reaper stopped Midway he was too scared
to do it something which he regrets to
this day the Revelation shocks Peter but
he decides to forgive his friend and
just like the last time he orders him to
put the coin inside the skull to check
what happens Michael who also wants to
know the truth obliges without thinking
much as soon as the coin is entered the
ground begins to shake and the Grim
Reaper Rises then the door opens and
from it emerges the same wagon from 30
years ago as the two friends watch in
horror a ghastly White Boy comes out of
the wagon he is none other than Sam the
boy who everyone thought was dead in a
State of Shock and utter disbelief
Michael approaches his childhood friend
and tries to initiate a conversation
unfortunately this turns out to be a bad
idea as the freak boy is not the same
Sam anymore he has come only for one
reason revenge in the blink of an eye he
snaps Michael's neck and renders him
unconscious or probably dead though
after this he goes after his childhood
bully Peter and brutally finishes him
off splattering blood all over the car's
windshield in the process at last a
paralyzed Michael who is lying on the
floor thinks to himself what if we went
to the beach instead I might that script
was almost as dumb as beans for
breakfast you know I'm saying the third
movie opens up in an Indian village
where two siblings Veer and Mira arrive
home to check up on their sick father
rajendra they both live in the cities
and are meeting each other for the first
time in years turns out rajendra has
texted them that he is going to die soon
but to their shock He is Alive and Well
preparing food in the kitchen the
siblings angrily confront the old man
demanding why he lied to them when he
knew that they have busy schedules in
response regendra says that he has to
discuss something very important
following this the family heads to the
living room where they sit down and have
a small talk unfortunately the siblings
start bickering as they blame one
another for their story state it is
revealed that their mother is in the
Next Room completely paralyzed and
unable to talk although the kids love
her very much they cannot see her in the
State anymore as the conversation wears
on we get to know some more secrets
about the family the sun Veer is
revealed to be a gambler who has stolen
jewelry from the house before and is
dealing with dangerous drug addicts and
other criminals while the daughter Mira
is a lesbian who ran away from home to
live with her girlfriend at present she
is failing to adopt a child the siblings
are at complete odds as they think of
each other as failures but let's be real
Veer is definitely the failure here
right am I crazy when the argument
starts getting violent regendra
intervenes and hands them a box inside
of it Veer and Mira find several toys
from their childhood which brings an
instant smile to their faces for a split
second they forget all their worries and
rejoice in the moment however their
happiness is short-lived as regendra
drops a bombshell he reveals that he has
actually sold this house and the new
owners are moving in the very next day
the children are left infuriated by the
news and they inquire why such a big
decision was taken without their
consultation the old man defends himself
by mentioning that he built the house
and he had every right to sell it with
the money gained from it he now plans to
live the rest of his life in the city as
the children listen in shock regendra
then says which one of you is going to
take care of your mother
in the next scene when the old man heads
to his room to pack his belongings the
siblings calmly discuss the matter Veer
asserts that he lives with dangerous
people so keeping his mom with him won't
be a good idea in response Meera says
that she's going to adopt the child soon
so she won't have time for anything else
their peaceful conversation once again
turns into an argument as both of them
don't want anything to do with their
ailing mother right then regendra
appears next to them and drops yet
another bombshell he explains that he
has injected their mom with a deadly
poison and in two hours she is going to
pass away without any pain as expected
this angers the children and they start
calling him a murderer they then proceed
to call the cops but regendra stops them
and explains how his life has become
hell nowadays every day he has to feed
his wife clean her feces stained bed
sheets and change her clothes he then
has to wash those clothes and dry them
to make sure that she doesn't develop
rashes regendra is tired of this life
and the worst part of it is that his
children are never around to support him
before leaving he brings out a syringe
and reveals that it is the antidote to
the poison he administered to his wife
earlier he then hands it over to his
children saying that whosoever wants to
save her will have to take care of her
for the rest of her life the movie ends
as regendra walks out of the house with
his belongings while his children are
left contemplating if they should save
their poor old mother or not oh dark
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching